hey 42 here macaques in Japan used coins
to buy vending machine snacks welcome to
RIF the docked village of guy fawn has
no roads its buildings are connected
entirely by canals and foot bridges
Beijing Seoul and Tokyo all mean capital
in their respective languages the
youngest pope was 11 years old
all blue eyed people are mutants the
first ones appeared as recently as five
thousand years ago more than 90 percent
of all the black currents that grow in
Britain go into Ribena the International
Space Station has cost more than 30
times its own weight in gold there are
four thousand eight hundred species of
frog in the world but only one of them
goes ribbit
the amount of water on earth is constant
and continually recycled over time some
of the water you drink will at one point
have passed through a dinosaur
almost all the Botox in the world is
made in a single factory in Ireland
every human being starts out life as an
[ __ ] it's the first part of the body
to form in the womb mushrooms are more
closely related to humans than to plants
[ __ ] don't have [ __ ] in 97% of bird
species the male's don't have penises
free percent of pet owners give
Valentine's gifts to their pets on
Valentine's Day at least a hundred and
nine journeys between adjacent London
Tube stations are quicker to walk it
costs more to make the cardboard box
that shredded wheat comes in than it
does to make the shredded wheat its
self thanks for the view subscribe for
more for CT